deep throat
told bob woodward in the basement of
watergate
follow the money it was true then
and it is true now the book jacket aptly
states that
the money and the power is a detailed
and illuminating chronicle of an
extraordinary place
and time and a provocative
reinterpretation
of 20th century american history
and i agree it's my privilege tonight
to introduce to you the authors of
the money and the power the making of
las vegas
and its hold on america 1947
to 2000 sally denton and roger morris
sally denton is a native daughter
of nevada she was born in elko
and she attended two years of school
at this very campus in fact a mutual
friend of both of ours and a political
science professor both of ours
upon greeting her tonight really had
some very fine words to say about her
and of course
she is no stranger to any part of the
great state of nevada
she is someone that i have known for 30
years
in fact over 30 years she hails from
an extraordinarily distinguished nevada
family
in fact her parents who many of us know
and treasure are in the audience tonight
ralph and sarah denton
sally is in a word courageous
she is of course an award-winning
award-winning
investigative reporter and it has been
interesting to follow her career
as she has traversed many parts of our
country
she is the author of the bluegrass
conspiracy
an inside story of power greed drugs and
murder
and again for that she was courageous
too
sally's husband and co-author is roger
morris
roger holds a phd in government from
harvard university
he served on the senior staff of the
national security council
under presidents johnson and nixon
roger has won several national
journalism
prizes he is the author of several books
including
richard millhouse nixon the rise of an
american politician
thus here tonight to discuss with us are
two people
who are well qualified to speak of
politics and government
and the growing dominance among other
things of money and politics
and many other things that they want to
share with us in conversation
i will introduce them to you both in a
minute nancy will
see nancy sally will come first to
the podium and then followed by roger
and then
jointly they will come to answer
questions please help me welcome
sally denton
i want to thank the attorney general of
nevada my friend frankie sue
one of the best public
officials that the state's had and i
think many of us wish that
she would be running for federal office
at a time right now when i think america
really needs cool and sensitive leaders
like she certainly would have been
or will be in the future
i also i want to say um thank you
obviously to the nevada humanities
committee for inviting us
and what a special honor it is for me
i came here really as a little girl in
1970 i was 17
16 going on 17 i think and
as a freshman living at nye hall and
i always feel like this is really my
home having
grown up in southern nevada i feel a
special affinity to reno i love it i
feel that this is my cultural and
intellectual
and political home base and
really where i got the roots of
everything that i would take
on that career that she was talking
about
weeks ago as i began thinking can you
hear me
everybody weeks ago as i began thinking
about what i would say in this address
and i hate speaking which is why i write
by the way i was thinking about what i
would say in this address to the great
basin book festival
i thought back on my 25 career as a
journalist
and the fact that almost every important
story i have ever worked on in any part
of the
en of the country from
organized crime to drug trafficking and
gun running
to political corruption at every level
sooner or later led back to las vegas
this is starting in my first journalism
career my first journalism job was in
1976.
from tail numbers on drug planes
bringing in loads of cocaine to remote
landing strips in northern new mexico
from murdered women in kentucky who had
ties to las vegas figures
from top secret equipment stolen from
china lake naval base in california
winding its way to las vegas from the
contract killing of a federal judge in
texas
being planned in a las vegas casino
from the watergate scandal that led to
skim from the howard hughes hotels
from the iran contra investigation in
washington dc
that focused on las vegas as a fount of
black money for covert government
operations
to the tens of millions of vegas dollars
finding their way
not only into the american political
system but into the
the political process of israel and
other nations
other counties other state governments
throughout the country
it would be these trails that eventually
inspired me to propose a book to my
publisher alfred knopf
about the dark side of the american
political and economic system
using las vegas as symbol and metaphor
for something larger
it didn't start out to be a book about
las vegas i propose that we look at las
vegas i had been as a reporter i had
been looking
constantly at bigger
national stories with the ties to las
vegas
and i was proposing that we look from
las vegas outward and see where that led
us
but then after the horrific events of
september 11th
las vegas suddenly seemed irrelevant and
trivial i sat in my home in santa fe and
thought
i have nothing to contribute to this
dialogue
for days i struggled with what i would
possibly contribute to you
as an audience and even to the national
dialogue in the context of a book
festival in northern nevada
then the inevitable trails to vegas
slowly emerged
here we go again i thought as i read a
headline
a banner headline in the las vegas
review journal possible las vegas link
probed
as many as seven of the terrorists
involved in the world trade center
attacks including pilots of the plane
of one of the planes into the world
trade center and the pilot of the plane
into the pentagon
were in vegas only a few weeks earlier
and then today's paper identifies yet
another conspirator arrested in london
who was in vegas in june flying giving
flying lessons to other conspirators
we have no idea what they were doing
there whether they were meeting with
co-conspirators
or plotting an attack on the strip or
hoover dam
typically the national media dismissed
reports of las vegas as anything more
than an aberrant playground in the
desert as
always the national the immediate
national tendency was to downplay the
significance of las vegas
as a deadly serious national emblem
every bit as symbolic of the american
dream as the world trade center
instead of recognizing and acknowledging
las vegas for the american mecca that it
is
the headquarters of an international of
the international underworld
the national media predictably focused
on the city's strip joints and
gentlemen's clubs
as if these deadly serious suicide
murderers went to vegas for something as
banal
as sex or pornography whatever the
reasons
arab terrorists like hundreds of
criminals before them
have found las vegas to be a haven and
in any case have found it to be a place
where the action is
whether the city was safe house or
target whether they were casing the
place
or retrieving and dispensing black money
muhammad atta and his cohorts
were simply the latest in a long line of
operatives to find their way
to this shadow capital las vegas
epitomizes both physically and
spiritually the ethic of modern american
greed
that these islamic fundamentalists as
well as millions of others in the world
suffer from an inferiority complex
brought on by our isolation and
wasteland mentality
we have been humbled by long neglect as
senator pat mccarran said decades ago
what began as a self-deprecating
humility led us into a rotten bargain
that has resulted in the exploitation of
the entire state
at the beginning of the 21st century the
casino industry is larger than state
government
and controls virtually every aspect of
nevada life
the terrorist events have shown in stark
portrait what can happen when the state
is so entirely beholden to one industry
in the last couple of weeks thousands of
casino workers have been laid off
and casino stocks are plummeting with so
little diversification of industry
nevada is particularly vulnerable to a
devastating downturn
today's paper again brings still brings
us still more layoffs
4 500 from mandalay bay alone the
terrible price
that will be paid by ordinary working
nevadans not by the fat cat executives
who so generously offered to to split
i think five million dollar take a five
million dollar pay cut among a hundred
of the top executives
i was raised in a nevada family where i
was taught to speak the truth regardless
of the consequences
and in this book i have called it as
i've seen it
and i have done so in the hope and
perhaps naive belief
that it is not too late to turn one of
the most exciting and dynamic cities in
the world
into a prototype for social values and
economic equality
to redistribute the obscene
concentration of power
held in the hands of a few in this state
i am repeatedly asked as i travel around
the country if i am opposed to gambling
and i'm always struck by what seems the
absurdity of their question
of course i'm not opposed to gambling
i'm from nevada and i always return to
the poignant words of senator estes
keifer
when crime boss meyer lansky asked him
what's so bad about gambling
you like it yourself that's right keith
offer answered
i just don't want you people to control
it those of you who have read the money
in the power
know that it is a critical and unsparing
view of nevada's 50-year long marriage
with what the keefer committee called an
alliance of gambling gangsters and
government
so it may seem strange to you to hear me
say that i wrote this book because i'm a
third generation nevadan
who loves this place like no other i was
born in elko
my grandmother was in the state
legislature my grandfather was a deputy
sheriff in lincoln county and himself a
gambler
in the railroad community of caliani my
father has practiced law in las vegas
for over half a century
my mother worked for senator howard
cannon my brother is a judge in las
vegas another brother is a pediatrician
and i have seven nieces and nephews that
live in las vegas
i care deeply about what happens to this
state
but i found when this book was published
that my view of las vegas was very
different from many friends
and family members whom i loved and
respected that we had very different
views of the same history
based on the different experiences and
knowledge that we brought to the subject
this book has had some wonderful reviews
and some sharp criticism
but literature in a democracy is part of
the process of differing
nevada like america has never been more
in need of a variety and diversity of
voices
writers must be the vanguard for the
truth as they see it
and if the truth offends so be it we're
all in this together but we don't have
to think the same way and we don't have
to come up with
the same homogenized excuse me
homogenized viewpoint
just as i love nevada i also love
america
i was as deeply and painfully affected
by the events of september 11th as any
other american
but already i sense that my thinking and
writing will once again strike an
uncomfortable
and unpopular accord and in the upcoming
months
as i inevitably criticize an american
foreign policy that is certain to offend
my sensibilities
it will not be for lack of patriotism or
love
roger came to this story from a
completely different vantage point
as a presidential biographer and
national security official in two
different administrations
he has his own perspective on las vegas
and the world
and i think it complements i think we
complement each other very well as kind
of the micro
and macro approaches to the same subject
matter so i'm going to turn it over to
him
and and just say that i'm
open to whatever questions that you
would have
um i want to thank um the honorable
attorney general
as well and and second the motion that
uh she should uh
uh charming as she is not be with us
tonight she should be in washington
we're in need of her
um i want to thank the the humanities
committee as well what you do here
is a marvelous service uh to the culture
not only of this community but to the to
the state at large
and keep up the good work even if they
even if they cut your budget
and uh and plead poverty from both
washington and carson city don't let
them get get you down
i want to echo a bit of what sally said
uh
i was not a native nevadan uh i had the
uh the misfortune to grow up somewhere
else
uh in the midwest in kansas city
although as you know there's a long time
tie between certain elements
in kansas city and and las vegas
but i came to love this place and
a writer i think must love what
what he writes about how else can you
sustain
that effort over the course of years of
research and of getting up every morning
and going to bed every night
living your conscious life and your
dream life
with this this terrible monster around
you
which is what a book turns out to be
it's a great deal of work
and in the end however unsparing however
critical our book is of nevada and of
las vegas
uh it is indeed a work of love for both
of us
uh you're very privileged to live in in
one of the one of the loveliest
uh cities on the face of the earth not
only the biggest little city but
certainly one of the most beautiful
but i came to this because i thought
there was
an incredible story here and a story
that
i had been missing in my other work in
national politics
writing about uh presidents and about uh
foreign policy in particular
there was always this darker shadow
element
of the story of richard nixon of bill
clinton
regardless of party or of time or of era
there was always
something missing in my view of the
larger story of american life and
politics in the 20th century
and unfortunately i found much of that
missing ingredient
in the story of las vegas as sally said
we tried to see
not las vegas as the world saw it from
the outside
but to fuel american history through the
prism of the strip
and when you look at the last half
century of america
from the vantage point of las vegas it's
not a pretty picture
we knew that that the city was run by
organized crime but we had no idea
that it was built by the proceeds of a
massive drug trade
that began far earlier than most
americans had ever known
uh when drug trade was uh interrupted by
world war
ii uh meyer lansky and the syndicate he
represented
uh began a very flourishing traffic
through mexico
in the 1940s and the proceeds from that
traffic
narcotics sold all over the united
states all over the western hemisphere
really
helped build the original casinos of the
strip beginning with the flamingo
but we discovered of course as well that
it wasn't
drug proceeds or vice profits or
organized crime alone
that built and financed early las vegas
it was america
it was wall street much earlier than
conventional history had had it with
junk bonds and steve nguyen and
milken and all the rest and that the
strip was financed as well by
by local nevada banks uh and by
uh substantial holdings of banks in utah
uh the money most of the money of which
came from the mormon church
it's a it's a very seedy tale of
american capitalism knowingly
participating
in the finance of organized crime and
enabling organized crime
to reinvest its profits in the rest of
the american economy
in real estate development in
agribusiness in petrochemicals
in entertainment in every sector of the
american economy including the most
advanced nature of telecommunications
and technology
until organized crime had extended its
hold and its influence and its ethic
throughout the nation far beyond its
original base of vice
in las vegas and other american cities
we came to conclude also that las vegas
was not the aberrant sin city of
conventional history but
uh really represented uh in a in a very
very
classic way uh the all-american city
las vegas simply did in the open what
the rest of america had been doing
behind closed doors furtively
in the shadows denying its essence and
its reality
for years and years and years every
major american city had been governed by
that furtive coalition
of gamblers gangsters in government uh
it's just that it didn't acknowledge it
or admit to it openly as las vegas did
las vegas was no more than a mirror
of the rest of the nation and of course
we concluded that that system of
intrinsic corruption uh that seamless
web
of political and economic complicity
came to dominate the national ethic as
well
until at the end of the 20th century the
ethic of greed and exploitation which
had been
the dominant mode of the strip became
the celebrated
ethic of the nation at large
that's why the book was called the money
and the power and it really is a
portrait of power
in modern america
i wanted to say and could say more about
that
and about nevada's peculiar compromise
but uh i felt i would be remiss tonight
if i did not change course somewhat for
the
the last portion of my address and talk
to you instead
about the relationship of all of this to
the events of september 11th
because that is quintessentially a
question of power as well
i came to learn at the beautiful knee of
my wife
um about nevada and about las vegas
um i aspired to be a foreign policy
expert and i have spent a good deal of
time
in afghanistan and in areas of the
middle east that are now
in the headlines of the american news
media
i have awakened in chihil saturn palace
in in
kabul and looked out uh at these guys
you now see on cnn
with the long rifles and the turbines
and they were when i was on the national
security council staff
my clients as they were known they were
my people it was my job to represent
them and their views and their interests
and their fears and hatreds
uh accurately to the president of the
united states
so i have a peculiar personal history
with this crisis that we are in the
midst of
and i wanted to talk to you briefly
about that
i wanted to tell you and share with you
um
what i saw and felt on the morning of
september 11th i was not in santa fe
with sally i was
doing research in in seattle and and
staying with my son who's a television
producer there and we were awakened very
early in the morning as you might
imagine as you were here i'm sure by the
news from his television station what
was happening in new york and we awoke
in time
to see on the screen uh the burning of
the first
world trade center tower and then to
witness uh the second attack
and everything that followed
at the time the night before i had quite
by chance
been reading a new book by salman
rushdie the great islamic
author who as you know suffered
intense personal very life and death
persecution
at the hands of some of these same
elements uh it's a book called fury
i recommend it to you highly it's a it's
a new novel
and i had underlined a passage in fury
which i thought about often
over the ensuing hours and the phrase is
simply this
i come to describe to you america in the
highest hour
of its hybrid omnivorous power
i thought about that omnivorous power
because uh
it certainly was the moment at which
those airplanes crashed into the into
the world trade center
uh and it uh is a moment that is gone
forever
we live in a world in which we are more
in contact
with the rest of the planet than ever
before and
seemingly in many ways less connected to
it
than ever before you know the opening
quote in the money and the power is from
michael herr
from uh from the enormous room it's uh
it's uh
he says there's no city like it for
connecting the unconnectable
there was no event it seems to me like
this one on september 11th
like it for connecting the unconnectable
and i wanted to i wanted to share with
you some of the things that i thought
some of the quite irreverent uh thoughts
that i had
as someone who had been in that part of
the world and who had been responsible
for making a part of of american foreign
policy which i think on the whole
has been in its own way as much a
disaster as the events of september 11th
i thought about all of the innocents
who were dying in front of my eyes
in those buildings and i thought about
all the innocents
who had been dying for so many years
uh out of our sight relatively speaking
i thought about the people of panama who
perished in that invasion
000 of them who were massacred in a
single neighborhood because we were
hunting down
general noriega who happened of course
as you well know to have been on the cia
payroll for years and years and years
i thought about the two million
vietnamese who by conservative estimate
perished under the american bombing i'm
talking about civilians not military
people
i thought about the million cambodians
who perished as a result of our policy
uh in in cambodia i thought about my
responsibility for an american policy in
africa
and in the near east and south asia
which had
uh perpetrated the assassination of
the first congolese prime minister
patrice lumumba and led to the
dictatorship of joseph mobutu
and on to the plunder and pillage of of
zaire
and to what is now an uncontrollable
epidemic of
of aids in africa which is killing a
continent
i thought about our overthrow of socarno
and indonesia
and the inheritance of the suharto
regime and
the deaths of hundreds of thousands
through political
torture and and suppression i thought
about the allende overthrow
and uh the repressions in chile i
thought about the thousands of
salvadorans i thought about
nicaraguans i thought about all of the
palestinians tens of thousands of them
who have been killed by american
gunships and by american aided military
efforts by the israelis
i thought about all of this because uh
because i knew about it
and i had long been ashamed about it and
because my first thought
quite frankly was that these planes
crashing into the world
trade center were not an accident not an
unprovoked
inexplicable attack they were quite
simply in a term we use inside the
government blowback
they were blow back for decades of
american
heedlessness and cruelty and savagery
abroad
often inflicted against civilians as
innocent
as those innocent souls who lost their
lives in lower manhattan
in the in the sheer 18 days
since september 11th 3 600
iraqi children have perished because of
lack of medicines
and immunizations and just because of
sheer starvation because of those
sanctions
and you may have noticed of course that
saddam hussein is still in power
it seemed to me that our failure to bear
witness
to all of this suffering in the world
was in stark contrast
to our very moving very very moving
and still continuing effort to bear
witness
to our own sacrifice we are indeed and i
suppose it's quite natural but there's
something
it seems to me also unnatural about it
so much more
willing to grieve for our own losses
than for the losses of humankind
and i thought we were a better people
i knew that the afghanis
who were sheltering the terrorists were
our people too
they were our creation after all the
mujahideen had
nothing to fight the soviets with in
technology or an organization or
anything else until we gave it to them
the cia spent billions as you must know
in that ten-year war against the the
soviets and not a single
senior person in osama bin laden's
organization
is not a graduate of that effort they
are all veterans of the afghan war they
were all in the pay of the central
intelligence agency including bin laden
himself i thought about the 43 million
dollars
that the bush administration this bush
administration just gave to the taliban
government in afghanistan
in may in may because they promise to
crack down
on drug dealers and opium growers
they clear 180 million dollars a month
by u.n
estimates in the drug trade and you know
that that drug trade launders much of
its money
through the city we were writing about
still and all
much of that money will find its way as
the 43 million dollars in your tax
tax money of course to to buy weapons
that will end up killing american kids
if we go into afghanistan
i thought about the billions that we had
spent on intelligence
that failed us completely and utterly at
a moment when we needed it most
what i thought at the end of that
terrible terrible morning
was that our citizens who were dying
were innocent but that our government
was not
today george bush on the radio said this
was a crisis not of our own making
he is either ignorant or drastically
mistaken
this is very much a crisis of our own
making
and it is to tie it up here in a nice
little package for you in my view
vegas foreign policy come home the book
tells the story of how vegas plays a
central role
in the corporatization of american
foreign policy from the 1950s on johnny
roselli and the boys go into central
america as enforcers and goon squads
for american businesses like united
fruit and others
they literally take over uh guatemala
after the coup in 1954
they're in cuba i mean it the story goes
on and on we tell it all
the cia plots to kill castro which
enlists the mob uh
hank greenspun and his his efforts in
arms trafficking for
for israel uh at one point in his
federal trial
uh he uh he is asked by the by the
prosecution if he'll make a statement
that
these were innocent arabs that he was
sending arms against and he says
innocent arabs there's no such thing as
an innocent arab
which is the attitude of course of of
millions of americans as well
and the drug trade ah the drug trade the
vast
fount of profits and of reinvestment for
vegas itself without the drug trade
vegas would hardly exist and without
vegas the drug trade would have a
tougher time existing
i don't approach any of this with clean
hands
i was as responsible for some of the
things that happened
in the the latter johnson administration
and the early years of the nixon
administration as anyone i waited
far too long to resign because of the
war
i got up in the morning and read those
casually lists and i participated in
meetings and i lied to the public
and i perpetuated myths i got along to
go along
i can say these things to you because i
am by no means approaching it from the
higher moral ground i just know we were
wrong
and we continue to be wrong and as long
as we are wrong in the world
we're going to face the kind of terror
and horror
that we faced on september 11. and
what's wrong with las vegas and what's
wrong with american foreign policy is
really very very much
the same thing i wanted to end by making
a
a special appeal to you
uh this is an appeal i suppose i should
frame to to writers but
writers are nothing without readers and
you are readers
i think we have at this moment a moral
responsibility unlike any other
generation of americans
vis-a-vis ourselves and vis-a-vis the
world
this world not only has changed it has
imposed upon
us a terrible terrible burden that we
must
meet if we do not
now speak out against the crowd
will if we do not repair
ignorance in our public process the
dysfunction
the sheer dysfunction of our political
and economic system
who will if we
do not ask that america transcend
nationalism at a moment when nationalism
seems to be everything
if we do not ask patriots to rise above
crude
and simplistic patriotism
if we do not ask the vengeful and the
brokenhearted
to rise above vengeance and
heartlessness who will
if we do not do these things
if we do not tell the story of the
murderers as well as the murdered
who will ever tell that story or
understand it
if not us who and if not
now when if
we don't tell the unwanted truth the
unpopular truth
then what shall we say if not here
in reno or in any of our communities
then where
and if not all of this together
if not a new sense of honesty and candor
with ourselves and with the world
and about america's responsibility in
the world
to ourselves and to others then why not
at a moment like this when bombs were
exploding all over paris
and you couldn't even go out to one of
those wonderful restaurants without the
danger of
of being killed during the algerian
revolt in the 1950s
uh the great french writer jean-paul
sartre
made an appeal to his countrymen and
bobby kennedy used to quote this
all the time at the end of his speeches
i thought it was a wonderful line
and sart had said perhaps we can never
eliminate
tortured children in the world but at
least we can reduce the number of
tortured children
and if you don't help us do this who
will
i don't think we can ever eliminate
terrorists or terrorism
but i devoutly believe from all i know
and all i've lived and all i've
experienced
and all i've researched as a writer that
we can reduce significantly
the amount of terror and the number of
terrorists all over this planet
and if you will not help us do that who
will
thank you very much we'll we'll be happy
to take your questions
if you have not already done so the
cards that were handed out to you as you
came
in if you will please uh pass those
towards the center
what we will do the cards will be given
to me i will read the questions
and then we will proceed with the
answers
uh what i'd like to do while we're
waiting um
for the questions and and certainly um
following up on something of interest to
me personally throughout the book
we've all heard las vegas referred to as
a mirror on america
share with us if you will i know roger
and i earlier this evening we're having
a very interesting conversation
about national politics and and
certainly the growing influence of um
money and politics in our country
and i would invite roger perhaps to
answer this question
any way he chooses with any example he
wants to because
i felt uh in the exchange of ideas and
looking at this book about and sharing
with
sally certainly a love for our state and
a love for every part of it
i think that in many ways it is
symptomatic of
what is going on in in in many other
parts of our country as well so
roger if you would begin in those
thoughts while the questions come up
we'll then proceed from there
well you know um the city was
was seen as this uh sin city in the
desert as the great aberration if you
can't do it at home
come to nevada but the truth was that
you could do it at home
in most of america if you knew the right
places to go the right doors to knock on
and the american political systems in
great american cities from new york to
los
angeles to san francisco uh not just in
reno and
and uh in las vegas were uh
were themselves these uh alliances of of
of organized crime and of uh and of
politicians
uh they were they were fundamentally uh
uh complicity of
of uh of the great economic interests uh
the political system
and uh and this under underbelly this
under underworld of american life um
and and that's how we saw las vegas
mirroring
uh the the rest of uh the rest of
america
um it comes to mirror and it comes to
represent the rest of america in the
1970s and 80s
as money comes to dominate completely
american politics as money had always
dominated politics in in nevada
it was still possible in the 1960s to
run for a federal office in many states
in the country
without being beholden necessarily to
one dominant
monopoly power it was never really
possible in nevada after the 1950s
to do that uh grant sawyer was perhaps
the last politician
uh in this state to be successful by by
carving out much independence from from
the
uh from the industry itself sally you
want to
i wanted to add something that i noticed
in nevada politics early that then
became kind of a national tradition
later which was kind of the revolving
door
from the industry from from law
enforcement into the industry
from the gaming control into uh six
figure jobs
and you used to i mean you see that now
all the time in
in american politics i mean people are
constantly going from the justice
department into
you know to work for for companies that
they were regulating
or investigating and and that was
something that was always even when i
was a journalist working for jack
anderson in washington in the 1970s
journalists were very aware of the
revolving door and it was really you
know a no-no and
and people were watching that now it's
done kind of routinely and i think it
was done
routinely and systematically in nevada
much earlier
a question you spoke of our moral
responsibility to speak out against the
crowd and ask america to rise above
vengeance and nationalistic patriotism
specifically for those of us who are
writers and those who are not
what do you see as the particulars of
our responsibilities and opportunities
as citizens in acting and moving forward
well i i think you've got to begin to to
speak out
and i think you've got to be come to
campuses like this
and uh and begin to organize and and
pull the kids together and begin to
begin to talk to them
this is a nation mired in an
unbelievable ignorance
about the world that has presented
itself on on our doorstep
at the windows of our tallest buildings
uh we don't know who we're fighting we
don't know why we're fighting we don't
have any uh much idea why they're
fighting
we have much less idea of of what our
our stake in interest really is
in this region of the world uh we have
very little idea of how our policy in
the middle east has really carried out
vis-a-vis the israelis or the arabs very
little
sense of its history uh we are we are
perhaps more totally ignorant
of this situation than we were of
vietnam and that
was nearly total ignorance and yet we
will be engaged with this part of the
world for a very long time to come with
casualties that may well exceed that
long black wall in washington
and they won't be combatants they'll be
innocents again
they'll be ordinary citizens you are now
the targets
in this war you're not bystanders or
onlookers
you are combatants and your government
has made you so
so that uh you must begin to speak out
you must
answer every demonstration like a
demonstration we saw today while that
peaceful little book festival was going
on in the banks of the truckee
uh up there less than a block and a half
away
uh were were guys in hard hats and red
flags
uh asking us to bomb afghanistan back to
the stone age i mean it's we have to
bomb them up to the stone age
uh you you've got to have began to stage
counter demonstrations
you can't let this you can't let this
hysteria sweep to sweep the nation or
sweep
its decision makers you have a
retrograde uninformed administration in
washington
fighting the the last war or the last
before last war
and uh you you've got to you've got to
begin to speak out and demand
of your elected representatives here and
in washington
uh much more enlightened views than just
to go along with the crowd
combining a couple of questions
drugs the mob and gambling are not
unique to united states
is there any country dealing with
these large problems in a way that can
give people
in america hope that there is a solution
or is the solution
that there is no solution
well i'm not sure there's any other
country in the world that's dealing with
the same combination
i mean most of the other countries in
the world are supplying us with the
drugs we're the
we're the consumer here but
i i believe that there is hope i believe
that there is
that there are ways through money
laundering
um legislation and
i mean i think frankly i think that you
know the the only way
the only hope of of stopping the flow of
drugs
is to get the government out of the
business of we've been
protecting drug traffickers as assets
just as we
just as the cia created osama bin laden
the cia has been
uh shoring up drug traffic major drug
traffickers
all over the world especially in central
and south america
under the guise of fighting you know for
democracy and fighting against communism
those are the people that we the the
rationales those are the people that we
have to deal with
and the quid pro quo is then to allow
them to
uh to traffic to our nation
and i mean we saw what happened when the
faa stopped all planes immediately
it brought everything to a standstill i
think if the united states government
wanted to stop drug loads coming into
the united states all they'd have to do
was shoot down one plane
and that would really put a damper on
the whole industry
um i just want to add one thing you
remember what gandhi said when
someone said what what do you think of
western civilization and he said i think
it would be a good idea
um you know there there is no anti-drug
campaign
not a real one in this country we tell
the story of operation casablanca in
which 70
major american banks most of which i i
suppose are here in reno and you
probably bank there i know i
i do uh 70 american banks were involved
in the in the laundering of
hundreds of millions of dollars that was
an investigation suppressed at the
highest levels of the us and the mexican
governments
um it touched raw nerves
you don't have a you don't have a
multi-trillion dollar world drug trade
without the complicity of governments
let's not kid ourselves
the book is probably most controversial
in las vegas
for its treatment of the political
children of the founding generation
as well as icons like hank greenspun
how do you interpret the second
generation's role in nevada
including a reference to here to
governor miller and
sedway
what's the question how do what should
the second generation do
yeah it says how do you interpret the
second generation's role and i think
for those of you who've read the book of
course there's a
mention certainly of former governor
miller and
and assemblyman sedway's father i think
it's
just sort of taking it from one
generation to the second generation
well i mean las vegas is a tiny town
when these men like hank greenspun and
and
perry thomas from you know valley bank
and bank of las vegas
uh i mean they were as one writer once
wrote they were building the city
working writing without a script
i mean it was really one of the most
amazing
success stories in the history of the
united states
and uh but it's a different city now as
anybody knows who's been there
and i think the second generation of
these i am assuming they're talking
about the descendants of the greenspuns
they have a great and the descendants of
of
of uh i mean i don't i don't know the
subway family
but or bob miller certainly but i think
the descendants of anybody
who made a fortune in this state
owe something back to the place and
i'm not i'm not sure that they're not
making that contribution
but i think they have the same the same
or more of a
i think i don't know a duty to the state
that they gain
so much from
um i i don't think we visit the sins of
the father no matter how many sins there
were
on any of the offspring here but uh we
try to deal for example with
with governor miller in terms of who he
was what his record was as district
attorney in
in clark county and we would tell the
story of what he didn't do
in a in the case of a murder
investigation and that took place in
in benny binion's horseshoe but um
and and certainly uh uh the greenspuns
are
our classic story uh the the offspring
do not begin to match
the the heft or the weight or the
majesty of the of the founding father
there
uh and the paper as you know as or you
may know is a
pale replica of what it once was but uh
but brian greenspun should be held
responsible for
i think the often irresponsible
journalism that he allows his newspaper
to practice and
and uh that's bad enough in its own
right we don't have to visit any of uh
any of daddy's
excesses on him
what is the attitude today of the
governing bodies of the mormon church
towards las vegas
well that's one uh door that's closed to
me i think
so i don't really know in fact my my
current book that i'm
uh just finishing is on
a massacre that happened in southern
utah in the 1800s
that the mormon church was involved a
mormon hierarchy was involved in
so we've heard absolutely nothing except
that the book
sells very well in salt lake city but
other than that we've had
absolutely no contact from anybody
this question is are you safe
and the cycle of greed and corruption
seems to feed upon itself
how do you break the cycle
i think i'll answer whether or not we're
safe let roger
break the cycle here you know i try very
hard not to think about that i've been
doing this kind of stuff for a long time
and i have three little kids and i get
very concerned from time to time
um and i i think it's just you know i
mean i'm more afraid
just kind of you know going outside of
my house with bears than i am
i mean i think i i focus my fear on
small things rather than
the the larger potential element of
danger
because it's it's what i do it's what
i've been doing for so long that if i
stopped and thought
god this is going to be dangerous then i
wouldn't do it i would be doing
something else and
i think it's just one of the the risks
of the of the job
um there certainly is no easy answer to
breaking the cycle of greed and
corruption because it is the american
way
uh it's we it's been we've been at it
here for
for well more than two centuries with
great success as you know
um it will not come alone from
grassroots popular
movements although it needs the impetus
and the
the spur of popular discontent which we
haven't even begun to
to see in this country but it will
require as the fall of the old soviet
union required
in the end extraordinarily courageous
and exceptional leadership
the soviet union did not collapse
because of popular demonstrations it
collapsed because it had a leader in in
mikhail gorbachev
who who felt that the system had to be
changed
and there were other people in the
leadership who felt it had to be changed
we don't have anything like that there
are no gorbachevs in
in american politics and until we have
one pray god until we have one
um i think that cycle will will continue
and
we he he or she could come from american
business
from the ranks of of academia could come
from any walk of american life
but uh we're going to need political
leaders
to reverse that trend and to tell us
remind us again
not of how tough or how big or how
vengeful we are but of what a decent
people we are
and that material wealth and profit and
prosperity
is not the ultimate value of human
existence
a couple questions about the whole
process of writing the book
first have the two of you collaborated
on other books
is each collaboration different how do
you divide
the writing and the research and then
closer to home what inspired you to
write
the money and the power was there a
seminal event a sudden rush of insight
or what and then finally again on
process please tell us something about
your approach to the work
when you started what was the plan how
did it evolve over time
in other words what did you think you
were going to write
how did you think you would do it and
did the plan change as it unfolded
so that's sort of a lot of questions
roll into
collaboration and the writing process
well we started uh as i said you know
when we first proposed the book to kanap
that it was kind of a germ you know an
idea about the the dark side of the
of the american system uh we went we
knew we were writing about las vegas and
we had kind of a rough
outline and um and we knew we were going
to follow the money
as from the very beginning and we really
we started at the library of congress
and we spent over a month in washington
living there
when we went to the library of congress
and we got everything every book that
had been written about
prohibition about organized crime about
the kennedy assassination about i mean
every
everything that covered every single
subject that we ended up dealing with we
were really tracing the rise of a
criminal underground
from the beginning in this country to
the to the beginning of the 21st century
the writing process was very different
we had never collaborate we collaborated
on some
small journalism pieces in new mexico
but
this was the first book that we did
together and
the process was i think quite different
from
what our publisher tells us most
co-authors do we really
we sat there we both researched
everything we were both fully
knowledgeable
about all of the subject matter and felt
that
i think roger felt that he didn't he had
to
learn a lot about nevada and las vegas
quickly
and i felt that i had to learn a lot
about the national historical
significance of events quickly so we
both felt that we needed to be
completely steeped in all
aspects of the research and when we sat
down to write we wrote it line by line
word by word which was a very
uh painstaking um endeavor
to say the least
i would have said painful
it actually was a wonderful process it's
the most wonderful literary experience
i've ever had
it's a lot more fun to argue with your
wife than it is to uh
to do this whole thing alone you know if
scott fitzgerald said uh oh there's
nothing like it it's just laying your
guts out on the table every morning
writing that is and this was really more
fun than that and i and i have to say
too that this process of learning about
nevada was really
more than that for me was learning about
a whole aspect of american history and i
thought i was rumored to be alleged by
some of my colleagues to be fairly
knowledgeable in this field
and i didn't know squat about a lot
and i learned a lot in this book and it
changed my life and my approach forever
and ever i'll never
i'll never write anything again uh
without being influenced by the
perspective that
that this book uh gave me and the book
i'm doing now
we're doing separate books but the book
i'm doing is a parallel
history of the united states and the
soviet union in the 20th century 1917 to
2000 not the cold war not their
diplomatic relations
but the internal politics on on two
sides
and uh the contrast between the pretense
of the two
capitalism and one side and socialism
and the other uh
between the pretense and the reality
disappointing on both sides
and i wouldn't i wouldn't have even
begun to take on a book like that
if i hadn't first gone to las vegas
i'm going to roll these last three
questions sort of into
one uh basically it's talk the questions
ask about whether the u.s
attorney in nevada not the attorney
general
is less eager to prosecute drug drug
dealers and other us attorneys of course
um
sally rogers may not know we just have a
new u.s attorney so i think that's
really not a
very fair question for them um but
basically the
the other two questions speak in terms
of nevadans and i think that
it could be not just nevadans but
americans
i have the courage to demand better
government
one that is not beholden to gaming
i don't know the new us attorney or what
the the policy would be
um i think that the uh that nevadans do
have a right to determine to demand
better government
and i think that's what i was talking
about when i i said that i think that we
have
this uh inferiority complex and i always
i mean it feels to me like
you know being the unpublished
struggling writer who
you know finally somebody says i'll
publish this for you and i'll give you
five dollars and it'll you know be
circulated to 20 people and you're like
oh thank you thank you thank you and i
think that nevada has always felt like
god you know as long as they want us i
mean we don't care who they are what
they are
or where their money came from you know
we're just glad that that somebody wants
us because
california is just right over there and
it's gorgeous and it has everything and
you know but we're stuck here with you
know what we all think is beautiful
but um most of the country has always
kind of made fun of us
and um so i think that we've gotten kind
of complacent i think nevadans have
gotten complacent
in demanding uh i mean what what strikes
me i've lived in new mexico now for 14
years and what strikes me
is when i come back to nevada and you
read these stories in the newspaper
about
you know some event that happened and
there's this kind of
you know re where the natural reaction
would be
outraged that that some public official
did this or did that
and instead it just kind of you know
goes along like well yeah that's what's
expected
and i think the kind of you know apathy
of that
also relates to america i mean you see
that a lot in the national
um you know stories in the national
media and the response and the
in the public and uh yeah i think that
nevadans have been really reluctant
i mean i think it really is the the pat
mccarran rotten bargain i think nevadans
have been very reluctant
to stand up to the power here and i
think it's not without reason it's a
it's an incredibly powerful uh syndicate
um i think this is going to be an awful
time
for america and domestic terms wars kill
reform
we know that historically and this war
is going to kill reform
don't look for anything to be anything
serious to be done about the environment
about social security about health care
about any of the issues that were
important
on the evening of september 10th or the
earlier morning of september 11th those
issues just disappeared
when that first plane struck the world
trade center
and the serious prosecution of the drug
traffic as apart from
from targeting the money laundering that
may help the terrorists
will not take place either law
enforcement will be totally obsessed
with this with this war on terrorism
and and every other concern in american
life will take will take a back seat
any issue that you thought was important
before is now is no longer
important and you will have to bring
those issues forward
and you will have to demand with
extraordinary courage and vigor
that of your of your elected
representatives and as far as the answer
in in nevada is concerned
about changing government or making good
government
you're going to have to have just like
the united states you're going to have
to have a politician with guts enough
to challenge this this huge frankenstein
monster that you have created
to do without its money to challenge its
power
to call it what it is to seek it out
to get it regulated in a serious way
and you're going to have to support
those politicians because they'll be
running against all the money in the
world
well folks that sort of concludes the
question part i'm going to ask sally and
roger if they have any final thoughts to
sum up
other than that on behalf of the
university of nevada reno
the chancellor who is here with us
tonight and certainly
all of nevada we thank you for sharing
your thoughts with us
it's a fascinating book and certainly a
university is a great place to have the
exchange of ideas that we've had tonight
so
on behalf of all of us present i would
ask if you have any final comments
and then we'll proceed to the book
signing and
and just meeting and saying hello to
sally and roger because i'm sure they'll
be with us for
a few moments after the closing of
tonight's event
i just wanted to say thank you again i
really
it's a great honor for me to be here and
i mean i really
i feel like i feel like i've come home
thank you
i just wanted to say that we ended this
book with more optimism than pessimism
and i still feel that way
despite the events of september 11 i
think nevada has an opportunity to
become
a model for the rest of the nation a
model of controlling
concentrated power you could you could
send every kid in this state
to a free education here through a phd
if you got hold of this uh this monster
and made it pay its way
you could have every public service you
want in every park and every facility
and every every town in nevada could
look like
a beautiful reno or riverfront today
and america could be a model for the
universe
it would be an irony i think that that
religious fanatics who accuse us
of of not having any values would
in the end give us back our values
and i think we have a we have an
opportunity to find that
thank you very much for having us
on behalf of the nevada humanities
committee thank you
all for being here thank you for
participating
the nevada humanities committee of
course does great work
uh if each of you or individually or
collectively
want to learn more about that i'm sure
there are folks here who would share
that information
please join sally and roger as we go
back to the foyer to
assign additional as they go to sign
additional copies of the book thank you
all for being with us this evening
sally denton is an investigative
reporter and previously the